Miguel is with us in Indiana I'm Miguel
how are you well hi Miguel how are you
good Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's up so I have a question
my wife and I just got married about two
weeks ago and we ngratulations
thank you how old are you 22
Wow fun how did you find me
you know I was I was just been online on
YouTube China where we you know trying
to get our finances together and I'm
just trying we're just trying to turn
our life around trying to get um you
know we're trying to get out of that
you're as soon as we can
good for you how much money do you make
what's your household income together we
make about a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars and you're how old
twenty-two I love you guys what do you
do for a living I work at a orthopedic
company mm-hm
and yeah I'm a machinist there so I make
you know we make we make pretty good
money but yeah I think um you know a
couple hundred grand when you're 22 is
called pretty good money in any book I'm
just saying and what does she meant what
does she do
she was huge she works in the same
company I work here we both we both work
in an orthopedic and that's how you
found each other okay I got it
so how much dad of you got so we got
about two hundred thousand dollars worth
the debt and my question for you is on
what um
100 and 130 is on our home and then the
rest is on vehicles we got a truck and a
car and actually we have three vehicles
why yes I mean yeah you know I'm not not
now we're trying you know to get
financially no why do you have three
vehicles there's two of you
oh um just one's a beater I mean I'm
part of part of getting out of dads
we're gonna sell one of our vehicles
mm-hmm okay so my question
for you is you know she has some thyroid
issues and where my question is should
we should I be tackling that that
head-on or should I put enough money in
our savings account that I can prepare
for you know some sort of emergency I
don't know whether I should be tackling
because right now I'm putting everything
you know where were you you have health
insurance we do have health insurance
does it cover her thyroid issues it does
I mean except deductibles and the
co-pays right yeah I mean we do have
that your uncle you make a hundred
eighty thousand dollars a year if
something pops up with a thyroid issue
and you've got to hit a deductible and
you've got to hit a a copay you can just
temporarily stop your get out of debt
plan you'll make it you make enough
money to cashflow and pay whatever the
health insurance won't pay okay and so
so you think that and you know we also
plan on having a family so do you think
I should be putting everything towards
it that or do you think I should save
any money at all whatsoever
you should put $1,000 in an account that
is baby step one you should none save or
invest another dime anywhere until
you're clear of your non mortgage debt
seventy thousand dollars worth you
should do that until nothing in a 401k
nothing in nothing until you clean up
this stupid mess you made mm-hmm the
great news is you have a huge shovel the
bad news is you dug yourself pretty
good-sized hole yeah so let's get out of
the mess let's get out no debt but your
house that is step two that's only
$70,000 you're talking about selling
with a car so it's even less than that
and you're gonna be dead free not
counting your house in less than a year
making a hundred and eighty paying
seventy that would make you living on
110 call me a wambulance you can do that
in one year yeah yeah okay so now that's
done it that's done now we build our
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses on top of that $1,000 account a
fully funded ranger the mortgage not
just bear with me bear with me baby step
three is pay is build your emergency
fund
when you have that done now listen to me
you're debt-free except your house
you've got twenty thirty thousand
dollars laying there to never be touched
unless there's an emergency then you
start your investing because now you've
laid the foundation and it's time to
build the house now we start putting
fifteen percent of our income into
retirement and then above that you start
putting money in kids college but you
don't have any kids yet and no you don't
get to save four kids you don't have and
no you don't need to worry about that
until you're actually pregnant we'll
discuss that when that happens then
we're gonna move on and knock this house
out
the great news is three years from today
you should be fully funding your 401 KS
you should be a hundred percent
debt-free house and everything mm-hmm
with the numbers you gave me that's very
doable and all you've got to do is focus
and concentrate and I'll teach you how
to do it it's called Financial Peace
University I'm gonna give you the
one-year membership to it and you're
gonna be able to sign up go through the
nine week class and you're gonna stay in
there it's got every dollar plus the
connectivity to your bank everything is
in there the whole thing works together
and I'm gonna give it to you as your
wedding gift so you hold on and I wish
somebody had taught me this stuff when I
was 22 I wish I'd made $180,000 when I
was 22 but anyway there you go so way to
go man way to go I'm proud of you guys